(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Meal kit companies
set out to disrupt grocery stores
and change the way we cook at home.
Now, there's 382 of them in the US,
a 300% increase from a decade ago,
when they were just 13.
Despite industry-wide growth,
the meal kit model faces an obstacle, you.
Of all the people who tried
one of five major meal
delivery services in 2022,
about 90% canceled their subscription
by the end of the year.
- Human behavior is very fickle,
especially when it comes
to food and beverage.
- [Narrator] And now, Blue Apron,
one of the earliest players is selling.
This is The Economics of Meal Kits.
This graph shows the
share of sales in the US
between the major meal
kit companies in 2022
Sunbasket and Marley
Spoon Inc., have 2 and 3%,
Blue Apron and Home Chef took 6 and 12%
while HelloFresh and its
subsidiaries ate up 78%.
But no matter their size,
many of these companies use
the same key ingredients
to find and keep customers,
price point, convenience, and variety.
First, get the customer.
Meal kit companies focus a
lot on the price per meal.
- [Presenter 1] Here's
how I make fancy meals
for under $5.
- [Presenter 2] Wow!
- [Presenter 3] Get 1.49 per meal.
- Our biggest competitor
are the offline grocers.
- [Narrator] Which is why
HelloFresh and Home Chef
say, "It's cheaper to buy meal
kits than to buy groceries.
- Wherever you source the ingredients
to do home cooking from scratch yourself,
that's our competition in some way.
- [Narrator] But what makes that possible?
- It's all about economies of scale.
- [Narrator] Brian Choi
has done market research
on the food and beverage
industry for 15 years,
and he says that,
"When it comes to keeping
prices low for the consumer,
grocery stores have an advantage
over most meal kit companies
because of the volume of
product they handle daily.
But similarly, the meal kit companies
that are best positioned
to offer the lowest price
point for consumers,
are the biggest ones, like HelloFresh."
- Economies of scale allow
us to get better pricing,
to get a better margin on the product,
and then to reinvest parts of that margin,
either into a better customer experience
or into lower pricing.
- [Narrator] Which means that at times,
the company can compete
on price with grocers,
but on a per-meal basis,
buying the ingredients
yourself from a grocery store
still tends to be cheaper,
especially considering
that you can always buy fewer ingredients
or go for cheaper options.
Whereas the minimum you
could spend on HelloFresh
and Blue Apron in a week is $60.95,
$12.49 per meal, at
least before discounts.
- It's sometimes hard to get people
over the purchase barrier.
That's why incentives are a key part
of our marketing or growth playbook.
For every dollar that we spend
on getting that group of customers,
it takes about six months
to actually earn that dollar
that we invested back.
- [Narrator] Which makes the next step
all the more important,
keeping the customer.
These are the customer retention rates
for the same five meal
kit companies in 2022.
In less than a year,
they all lost the vast
majority of the new customers
that bought their first
meal kits in January.
One possible reason everyone
drops off, the discounts.
- They're doing their own mental calculus.
They're like, "Wow, $12 meal
is very different from the $4,
you know, based on the promotional rate."
- [Narrator] When you
introduce a product to someone
at a severe discount,
you may get more people to try it,
but when the discount goes away
and they have to pay full price,
it may not be worth
that new price to them.
- One thing about the American consumer
is they don't like
dramatic change in prices.
- [Narrator] So how do companies
get retention rates up?
One way is to offer the discounts again,
and hope that they entice
customers to return.
And another is to add more
convenience and variety.
- The biggest value
proposition is the convenience.
- [Narrator] The big thing
meal kits offer to consumers
is a convenient way to cook at home.
They ship to your door
and give you pre-portioned ingredients
for relatively simple recipes.
- But when you stack that versus
the other options that
are there for consumers,
the collective value proposition
has diminished significantly.
- [Narrator] With restaurants
and grocery stores
offering delivery to your door,
it's hard for meal kits
to offer a unique
convenience to customers,
and getting pre-portioned ingredients
maybe more convenient if you
want to cook for yourself.
But Americans only cook an average
of 4.5 meals at home per week.
But companies across the meal kit industry
are expanding their offerings,
and one of the common ones
isn't a meal kit at all,
it's just pre-made meals.
- [Announcer 1] Factor has
chefs cook meals for you
and then they deliver
them fresh to your house.
- [Announcer 2] They have oven-ready meals
with everything included
and fast and fresh meals
that can be done in 15 minutes.
- As you grow your customer base
and you grow your assortment,
you also tend to give
customers a lot more choice.
- [Narrator] And more choice
means you're more likely to get customers
to spend more with your company,
but it's yet to be seen
how much these new offerings
will increase retention rates
across meal kit companies,
plus retention rates aren't everything.
Looking back at this chart,
Blue Apron sits slightly above the rest,
which Choi says, "May be because
it offers slightly more
options and customization."
But Blue Aprons' revenue has
declined greatly since 2017,
then, there's profit,
Both HelloFresh and Blue Apron
got off the ground
by raising hundreds of
millions of dollars in funding,
in 2017, they both went public,
then their paths split.
Blue Apron's revenue has slowly declined
with just a slight increase
during the industry's pandemic boom.
HelloFresh on the other hand,
has been consistently
profitable since 2017.
Looking at its revenue,
you see constant growth,
even after the pandemic shutdowns ended
and people could eat at restaurants again.
- Once you establish yourself
as the leader in that space,
it becomes very, very hard to be disrupted
because you need to solve
a lot of complex problems
over and over again to
get to that position.
- [Narrator] While both faced stark drops
in their share prices,
the New York Stock Exchange
threatened to delist Blue Apron
after its stock dipped below a dollar,
the company shifted to an
asset-light model, scaling down,
and offloading many of its
operations to another company.
Then it announced its
selling to Wonder Group,
a food delivery startup,
and return to being a private company.
Another key step is to differentiate.
The barriers to enter the meal
kit industry are fairly low,
which is partly why
there are so many meal
kit companies today.
- But the barriers to scale
and build a big business
are actually really high
- [Narrator] And why it's important
for each one to stand out
if it wants to survive.
Take Methodology, a small
meal delivery company
that started in 2015,
it doesn't offer meal kits at all,
instead, Methodology sends out
four or five days' worth of pre-made meals
with ingredients you're less
likely to find in other kits,
like nopales, cacti, and purslane.
- Our audience is basically
who I was when I started the business.
They're really time-starved,
so they don't have time to cook
healthy meals on weeknights,
and as far as their incomes,
most are making in the
several hundred thousands,
if not more than that.
- [Narrator] Most other companies
compete at a price point
around $8 to $15 per
serving without discounts.
But Methodology costs
around 17 to $30 per meal.
- Our sweet spot actually
is men who live on takeout
'cause they're already doing it
three to four times a week minimum,
they're spending 35 on average per meal.
- [Narrator] And it
doesn't offer discounts
at nearly the same rate
as the other companies.
The average discount for a Methodology Kit
is 10% off a customer's first week.
Nguyen says, "This model
has allowed the company
to be profitable from year two."
- We have customers who have spent
over a hundred thousand dollars with us
because we really are a lifestyle
for our target customer.
- We're operating in one of
the largest consumer categories out there,
which is food at home.
So in my view,
a large category will always attract
sort of like new business models,
new entrants in the category, and so on.
- [Narrator] Grand View
Research forecasts that
the revenue across the
US meal kit industry
will reach $64.27 billion by 2030.
- Do I believe the numbers?
- I think they're probably
a little bit too optimistic.
- I don't know what the food industry
will look like in five or 10 years,
but I do think that we
can play a really big role
in shaping the future
of the food industry.
I think in 10 years, we'll probably see
one or two major players in the industry
still operating in that space.
I'll also expect to see some companies
that have gone bankrupt
or acquired by some of the larger players.
(rhythmic music)